[Musique]
forcément de ce qui s'est passé le 15
avril 2019
vous souvenez ou pas mais si c'était
l'incendie de Notre Dame et bien on va
parler de cette incendie mais d'autres
choses d'une fiction qui essaient
greffée sur cette incendie avec l'eau et
Michaud bonjour bonjour Patrice vous
publiez justement les lettres de
Notre-Dame
c'est aux éditions du soldat du feu et
dans une collection qui s'appelle de feu
et d'encre et on reviendra un petit peu
sur cette maison d'édition tout à
l'heure
voilà 15 avril 2019 c'est ça exactement
vous étiez où moi j'étais dans mon
appartement à Paris pas très loin de
Notre-Dame et je me souviens que depuis
ma fenêtre je voyais la fumée qui
s'échappait et on était sorti avec mon
copain on se balader sur s'avancer pour
nous aussi assister à cet événement à
cette terrible
et on n'a pas pu trop s'approcher parce
que
je dis il y a peut-être chez vous deux
sentiments alors
on va parler parce que je pense que vous
êtes quelqu'un qui est très intéressé
par l'histoire par nos racines par nous
on vient parce qu'il s'est passé avant
donc par le patrimoine aussi
et puis
vous êtes d'une famille de pompiers
c'est ça mon grand-père était pompier à
Saint-Étienne mon père et pompier aussi
à Saint-Étienne mon frère a fait les
jeunes sapeurs-pompiers quand il était
au lycée donc j'ai toujours baigné un
peu dans cet univers des pompiers et
quand
évidemment vous pensez comme tout le
monde à Notre-Dame qu'est-ce qui va se
passer est-ce que ce que on va pouvoir
arrêter le feu assez vite etc mais
est-ce que vous vous dites aussi il y a
des pompiers qui sont là et ça pourrait
être ça aurait pu être mon père ça
aurait pu être exactement moi j'ai pensé
au risque qui prenait à comment ils
avaient enfin comment ils faisaient pour
pour éteindre cette incendie comment
combien de personnes étaient sur place
comment ils allaient essayer de sauver
la cathédrale sans mettre en péril
eux-mêmes leur vie et des idées décrire
un roman
qui part de cette incendie elle est
venue assez vite j'ai toujours voulu
écrire j'ai toujours plus ou moins écrit
et après un jour je me baladais à côté
de Notre-Dame c'était pas très très
longtemps après l'incendie et j'ai une
idée qui a commencé à germer alors
l'idée elle est venue pas forcément
longtemps après l'incendie mais c'est
vrai qu'il a fallu quand même plusieurs
mois pour que elle se précise pour
qu'une intrigue commence à vraiment
naître et pour que je me dise bon il y a
quelque chose il faut quand même que je
fasse quelques recherches et que
j'essaye de de la concrétiser est-ce que
peut-être intérieurement
je sais pas il y a peut-être c'est vous
aussi parce qu'ils ne sont devoir chez
mais peut-être devoir de témoigner et il
fallait que vous trouviez
l'intrigue le moyen de de d'écrire sur
ce drame bah c'est sûr que même en étant
d'une famille de pompiers vous imaginez
bien que moi je ne le suis pas donc il y
a beaucoup de choses que j'ignorais
totalement si c'est un monde très
compliqué là hiérarchie les pompiers de
Paris c'est aussi quelque chose de
complètement différent parce que les
pompiers de Paris sont des militaires
donc c'est
encore différent mais du coup voilà donc
il y avait vraiment cette volonté de
rechercher
d'en apprendre plus sur eux et
d'apporter quelque chose avec ce livre
et il y avait aussi une grosse volonté
de rendre hommage aux soldats du feu
parce que pour moi c'est ce que j'ai
toujours vu en voyant mon père partir en
intervention on attend en entendant les
récits
avec quelques drames qui se sont passés
autour de lui avec certains de ses
collègues qui sont tombés au feu
je me suis dit c'est on en parle pas du
tout des pompiers dans les livres
énormément la police
cette envie quoi de témoigner de et de
rendre hommage aussi à ce qu'on appelle
des soldats du feu alors le roman
commence avec
votre héros qui s'appelle William
qui est donc pompier à Paris qui qui va
être appelé à Notre-Dame
et là c'est vrai que c'est description
vous avez travaillé là pour vous avez
des témoignages si ça va mon premier
chapitre effectivement c'est le déroulé
de l'incendie de Notre-Dame on se
retrouve dans les flammes et on suit
heure par heure minute par minute ce qui
s'y passe et ça bah j'ai lu énormément
de livres sur l'incendie de Notre-Dame
j'ai pris des comptes-rendus
d'intervention pour être au plus proche
de la vérité après j'ai bien sûr pris
quelques libertés mais dans l'ensemble
j'ai essayé de rester au plus proche de
la vérité tout ce dont je parle les
heures tout ce qui se passe les prises
de décision sont des vraies choses par
exemple on a récupéré tous les éléments
historiques dans la cathédrale comme la
couronne d'épines ou autres c'est
vraiment des choses qui se sont passées
exactement et puis et puis il y a à la
fois pour cette le métier du pompier
face à cette incendie et puis il y a la
vie aussi comment ils vivent dans un
petit appartement il déménage c'est leur
quotidien mais au final ça c'est très
intéressant et et c'est vrai que
peut-être parce que oui voilà vous êtes
familière de de ce métier de peut-être
que vous voulez voilà vous connaissez
mieux que d'autres personnes une
personne non je dirais pas ça
qu'il le vivent c'est très bien voilà
c'est l'expression mais oui je le
connais un petit peu c'était vraiment
cette volonté d'humaniser aussi les
pompiers que derrière c'est les gens qui
viennent nous aider quand on a un
problème quand on appelle le 18 ben il y
a des vrais hommes des vrais femmes qui
ont un quotidien qui mettent en bas qui
mettent en parenthèse de temps en temps
leur vie et qui retournent à la réalité
après les interventions est-ce que
justement ce sont les des moments ou des
femmes et des hommes se comportent en
héros qui vous attire
je sais pas pour moi c'est le fait qui
peut-être
on parlera de la résistance tout à
l'heure
c'est vrai que ça m'attire mais je pense
que ce qui m'attire aussi c'est ce côté
ou pour eux je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
conscience d'être à ce point des héros
c'est leur quotidien c'est ce qu'ils
font tous les jours c'est une habitude
ils sont entraînés pour ça et ce qu'ils
s'en rendent compte encore qui sont des
héros est-ce que nous aussi on s'en rend
suffisamment compte parce qu'au final
pareil ils font partie de notre vie
quand il y a un incendie quand il y a un
chat dans un arbre on va appeler les
pompiers quand voilà on a un problème de
santé et qu'il faut une ambulance on
appelle directement les pompiers en
premier
nous on s'en rend compte et pour faire
bien ce métier il faut en effet que ça
devienne presque routine enfin peut-être
pas le mieux adapté mais que il y ait
des codes qu'on respecte des voilà et
c'est pas en effet ce qu'on portait je
dirais-je
bien le fait je pense qu'ils sont même
pas forcément conscient au bout de
plusieurs années de carrière qui sont
qui font des choses héroïques
on ferait jamais ça parce que c'est vrai
que parfois voilà ils vont sauver des
gens de leur vie quand même et parfois
parfois il n'y a personne qui d'ailleurs
qui meurent alors on va revenir
l'être de Notre-Dame justement aux
lettres c'est le cas de le dire parce
que William dans cette lutte contre
contre le feu un moment il découvre
quelque chose il découvre quoi derrière
une pierre qui bouge il va découvrir une
pochette noire en cuir qui semble
ancienne et dedans des lettres d'un
homme à une femme qui date de la seconde
guerre mondiale et donc il va lire ses
lettres plusieurs jours après
l'intervention et il va se mettre à la
recherche de cet homme et de cette femme
il va vouloir savoir ce qui s'est passé
ensuite la suite de leurs histoires de
leur histoire c'est une dizaine de
lettres et il veut comprendre ce qui
leur est arrivé et
en effet alors il y a des lettres il y a
aussi le journal
d'Alexandre qu'on va découvrir aussi
alors ça c'est dans les archives
il y a les archives des pompiers aussi
ça c'est très important ah oui il y a
des archives des pompiers et donc
effectivement toute la partie du journal
d'Alexandre et écrite bah c'est son
quotidien pendant la guerre 39-45 en
tant que pompier de Paris donc
quand tu commences à il se demande ce
qu'il va faire dans la vie en gros et
puis et puis il devient pompier et puis
il y a en effet cette cette période de
la guerre et cette histoire d'amour
terrible bactéries on peut pas on peut
pas trop dire on peut pas trop dire et
c'est vrai que pour moi au final à force
de l'avoir écrit de l'avoir pensé je la
vois plus forcément cette histoire
d'amour je sais qu'elle est là mais il y
a eu tellement d'autres choses parmi les
recherches parmi les pompiers
elle est secondaire elle est belle et en
même temps elle s'efface au profit
d'autres choses
comme on dit
mais on peut dire quand même que William
quand il trouve ses lettres il est voilà
il est touché quoi il se dit il faut
qu'il faut que je retrouve qui était
cette Alexandre qui est cette charlotte
enfin les retrouver
il y a on peut dire qu'il y a un enfant
ou pas
mais ce qui est ce qui est assez
formidable c'est qu'en effet vous
décrivez toute cette période tragique de
la guerre avec en effet d'un côté
à la résistance de l'autre la
collaboration et il y a
il y a des faits
[Musique]
vraiment existé exactement mais en fait
toute la partie dans le passé c'est
vraiment basé j'ai un sur des faits
réels j'ai un auteur spécialiste de la
gare 39-45 qui m'a beaucoup aidé en me
donnant beaucoup d'informations sur
cette période et j'ai aussi rencontré
des pompiers de Paris et les archives
justement je suis allée aux archives de
pompiers de Paris pour avoir des comptes
rendus d'intervention donc toutes les
interventions dont je parle c'est des
vrais interventions il y a une un fond
absolument formidable enfin
d'archives ça c'est je savais pas du
tout qu'il y avait ça c'est pour les
historiens c'est une mine quoi
j'ai découvert des choses en fait sur la
sur les pompiers de Paris pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale que j'ignorais
totalement par exemple je savais pas que
c'était les seuls militaires qui étaient
dans Paris après voilà donc c'est et qui
qu'ils ont énormément
œuvré pour aider les gens pour aider
pendant l'exode j'ignorais totalement
que les pompiers de Paris d'une certaine
caserne avait acheté une vache qu'ils
avaient mis au jardin du Luxembourg pour
avoir du lait pour nourrir les bébés qui
qui était victime de l'exode donc
c'était des choses je me dis c'est on ne
connaît pas
alors
on peut on peut dire ce qu'il a fait ce
que ce capitaine sardinet bien sûr
43 en pleine occupation par les
Allemands
tous les pompiers en fait ont été
obligés de décrocher les les drapeaux
français qui étaient sur toutes les
casernes et sur la Tour Eiffel aussi
donc tous les drapeaux français et lui
il a été à l'origine dans des premiers
mouvements de résistance au sein des
pompiers et donc il a monté un réseau
avec plusieurs hommes il a été arrêté
une première fois relâcher puis arrêter
une seconde fois il a eu de la chance
parce que final il a il a pas été
fusillé ou autre mais c'est vrai que il
y a quand même beaucoup de chance d'en
réchapper vu tout ce qu'il a réussi à
faire et les personnes qu'il a réussi à
emmener avec lui et la beauté de
l'histoire c'est que quand il y a la
Libération de Paris il va avoir sa
vengeance et dire qu'il va les
raccrocher le drapeau français sur la
Tour Eiffel exactement ça je trouve
c'est magnifique de se dire que c'est un
pompier de Paris
elle est magnifique et puis ça te dit
quelque chose justement du courage aussi
de de
ces pompiers et voilà
d'Alexandre pas trop dire mais lui aussi
il va être confronté à cette guerre et
va être dans le camp de la résistance
Alexandre c'est vraiment un personnage
qui est fictif par contre tout ce qui se
passe autour de lui c'est des choses qui
sont vraiment passées la caserne dans
laquelle ils travaillent c'est une
caserne qui existe vraiment et le
quotidien de la caserne j'ai essayé de
le rendre le plus réel possible et de
m'inspirer de fait donc toutes les
arrestations par exemple qui se passent
dans cette caserne les arrestations de
résistance ce sont des vrais des vrais
arrestations donc Alexandre effectif
mais au final ça aurait pu être un des
pompiers qui qui était à cette époque là
absolument et Charlotte alors
pas tant que ça dans le livre elle est
où c'est vrai oui c'est pas c'est à
personne très essentiel mais il y a pas
il y a pas énormément de pages
on peut pas il faut lire parce qu'elle
est la partie à une famille etc on va on
va pas mais mais c'est un personnage que
vous aimez quand même beaucoup j'admire
beaucoup de son courage parce que je
trouve qu'elle aussi elle a quand même
un certain courage elle se dresse contre
sa famille elle elle a ses propres
convictions
donc c'est elle a quand même un certain
courage même si c'est pas forcément
celui de l'action s'il y a énormément de
types de courage et puis après elle va
quand même
je peux pas forcément
tragique
mais jusqu'au bout elle aura quand même
le courage de croire en ses rêves
Alexandre donc
le travail des pompiers ça consiste à
empêcher que le feu détruise
est-ce que justement empêcher la
destruction des chefs-d'œuvre et
peut-être de notre mémoire c'est quelque
chose que vous considérez comme
important
oui pour moi c'est très important
l'histoire c'est quelque chose de très
important pour moi je suis pas du tout
une spécialiste mais j'adore plusieurs
périodes de l'histoire j'aime bien de
ton temps m'intéresser à une période en
particulier et je me dis que c'est ces
périodes là qui font qu'aujourd'hui on
est notre pays est ce qu'il est que nous
on est ce qu'on est on est nous-mêmes
parce que notre famille a fait si ça
donc l'histoire oui elle est importante
et la préserver la garder c'est quand
même quelque chose d'essentiel et c'est
pour ça que rendre aussi son histoire à
une famille c'est le geste que fait
William dans le livre c'est il veut
essayer de retrouver la famille pour
leur rendre les lettres et leur rendre
leur histoire c'est quelque chose que je
trouve important pour qu'ils aient la
connaissance qui sachent ce qui ce qui
s'était passé
à peu près
et non mais c'est bien parce que parfois
vous pensez qu'il est important de voilà
de savoir d'où on vient quoi savoir
qu'est-ce qui ont été dire les
soubresauts de notre histoire qui jouent
pas toujours facile et prenez la période
de
39-40 qui était en effet des périodes
noires de notre histoire de noir et il y
a les deux de côté à chaque fois
et au final ça a été quand même aussi
une période
d'entraide de gestes héroïque de
voilà aussi terrible que ce soit les
personnes qui l'ont vécu ont réussi à en
faire quelque chose qui comptait pour
eux et ont dû le vivre au quotidien et
au quotidien bah c'est comme notre
quotidien à nous oui il y a des moments
où on est triste mais il y a des moments
où on est heureux et dans chaque journée
on arrive à trouver des petites choses
et alors là où nous c'est plus facile de
trouver des petites choses eux
arrivaient à trouver des petits moments
de bonheur avec une petite soirée ou
voilà des dans un contexte beaucoup plus
compliqué vous êtes revenu à Notre Dame
oui j'y vais souvent mais c'est là-bas
d'ailleurs que j'ai mis mon point final
à mon histoire et pendant l'écriture j'y
suis souvent allée j'écrivais souvent à
côté de Notre-Dame c'était important
pour un peu avoir cette
l'atmosphère
absorbé par l'ambiance quoi
alors un mot de cette maison d'édition
qui s'appelle des soldes du feu
c'est une maison d'édition qui a
participé
des livres à destination des pompiers
donc il y a plusieurs types il y a des
manuels et il y a des exercices c'est ça
des beaux livres sur le métier de
pompier et ils ont décidé de créer deux
feuilles d'encre donc cette nouvelle
ligne de fiction et
donc c'est la fiction exactement c'est
de la donc là où ça se dessine plutôt
soit un public pompier mais aussi c'est
pour faire connaître ce quotidien des
pompiers au nom de pompiers justement
pour pour rendre justice à ces héros de
l'ombre et si on veut se procurer des
lettres de Notre-Dame on va sur le site
de oui sur le dos du feu c'est ça il est
disponible sur le site de la maison
d'édition donc Salda du feu il est aussi
disponible sur Amazon et en ebook sur
toutes les plateformes
de lecteur déjà pour l'instant vous
voyez quelques-uns après j'en ai eu
aussi de gens que je connais donc c'est
toujours particulier et alors pour
l'instant c'est plutôt positif
j'espère que
il est tout ce plus
je dirais que c'est plus
Alexandre et son histoire
exactement Alexandre et son histoire et
ce qui se passe dans son quotidien de
pompier je dois dire que même moi
en l'ayant relu plusieurs fois pour la
correction les parties où j'ai été le
plus
ému où je me suis dit j'ai écrit ça ou
j'étais le plus fier c'était vraiment ce
genre de c'est parti un peu sur
Alexandre sur la vie d'Alexandre merci
beaucoup merci vous êtes en train de
travailler un autre livre je suis en
train de travailler à notre livre pas
dans le monde des pompiers cette fois
mais voilà j'ai commencé des recherches
de l'histoire toujours
voilà vous êtes replonger dans dans ce
terrible drame de l'incendie de
Notre-Dame mais après avec une fiction
qui va vous porter dans la période de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et une histoire
d'amour avec ce que sont les histoires
d'amour parfois elle s'est remis de mal
en général comme disait
véritable Mitsouko merci beaucoup colo
et Michaud merci lettre de Notre Dame
voilà
[Musique]